more exciting than breakfast
and a lot more enjoyable to cook brunch
is ideal for sharing
first up my simple and delicious
frittata
eggs are great they are so versatile and
once you've mastered how to cook them
trust me the door then opens to a wide
range of delicious options
this is like a triple omelette but a lot
more ingredients than a normal
mesh we'll start off with some lovely
smoked bacon slice
the bacon bacon in no salt
little touch of pepper start off on a
high heat get that bacon really nice and
crispy
otherwise you just boil the bacon and
it's got that soft
unpleasant texture in the frittata turn
down the gas
and now start adding your veg roughly
chop a red pepper
and add it to the pan
the peppers and the bacon take the
longest so they've always got to go in
first
now soak them off and the peppers have
been cooked now from that sort of
rendered fat from the bacon
and then the spring onions just bunch
them up
slice them i want them on an angle so
they come like little
green diamonds spring onions in
now for the eggs cracking the eggs
for that size pan seven or eight eggs
i want to fill it right to the very top
and more importantly when i
turn this out i want it like a gato nice
and thick so
slice through and seal those wonderful
verge
[Music]
i'm gonna season the eggs with some
parmesan cheese
be quite generous because it adds a
really nice
saltiness
[Music]
fresh ground pepper and then whisk
whisk up those eggs nicely
then add peas to the pan and to give the
dish a wonderful aromatic freshness
some fragrant chopped basil i want to
chop that
sort of roughly because i want to see
those flecks of green
going in i want it looking charming
and how many times have you seen a dull
omelet
frittatas in my mind really helped
encapsulate the
magic of having savory eggs
cooked beautifully but with texture
now just before we add the eggs i've got
this
beautiful little goat's cheese and it's
strong and powerful
so i want to slice it
into little chunks and then just
have it dotted around i want to discover
these little pockets of
creamy goat's cheese now slowly add the
eggs
fill that right up
and get your spoon now just let all that
egg go down to the bottom
bring it back up to the boil and sort of
clean around the sides and then some of
this delicious
salty creamy goat's cheese over the top
now i want it melting like a
perfect slice of cheese on toast
nice now from there turn the grill on
for four to five minutes
now just looking at that
delicious take a little paring knife and
just
make sure it's released
on the sides just take your panel
tap that will hopefully release the
frittata from the bottom of the pan
now the board over the pan
turn that gently and just
shake say a little prayer and lift off
beautiful now
from there on there it's there look
now slice
through
you can see how soft and creamy that is
in the center
and that goat's cheese is just melting
almost like a little sauce inside
it's so exciting but more importantly so
easy to do
it's got texture it's got creaminess and
that for me will beat
any omelette for brunch serve with a
stack of hot buttered toast and a
steaming pot of coffee
this easy frittata turned the humble egg
into the perfect dish for kicking off
the weekend
[Music]
soft fiery and irresistible spicy
pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination
when it comes to brunches you don't have
to stick to the old standbys
these delicious spicy pancakes are
really great alternative
but more importantly so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning
the salt helps to dry out the cumin even
more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up and then just slice
nice little thin slices in there
and then keep that bunched up shake the
chilli
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot now
garlic nice now
add olive oil to your toasted cumin
seeds and then with the garlic
ginger and chili lovely
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but
the time i spent in india everybody was
eating something savory for breakfast it
was extraordinary
into your bowl and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
to a hot pan
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
then finely slice an onion onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and look at the color
an instant change leftover potatoes
just slice them
the smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes
across the pan while the potatoes
stained i want them sort of absorbing
all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge season those
potatoes and it really helps to bring
out
the spice beautifully
[Music]
they're ready turn off the gas and let
them sit there and absorb all those
flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic
chili ginger and cumin seeds touch
salt and pepper nothing worse than the
bland
pancake
one whole egg milk hold the jug with one
hand
and whisk we have a secret to get that
really nice smooth paste but
whisking that egg first and brings it
together and then you're milking
don't put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in it really
helps it
not going lumpy look at that
milk here and the secret for me is to
have a nice thin mix
now just a little teaspoon of oil
that helps to bring a nice crispy edge
to the mixture now just taste it
that's the texture pan on the larger the
pan the better
it helps to create a nice thin even
surface i want that
mix going all the way around the pan
before you put the mixture
into the pan make sure you give your
pancake mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil get that nice
whisk with one hand pan to the mix
in
one and a half ladles and then roll it
round
so it's really nice and thin i want to
see the ginger
the garlic that's what i'm looking for
in there
now back onto the heat it only starts to
remove
from the bottom of the pan and lifts
itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles confirm that it's
just starting to lift off
the pan a little shake that releases it
and then just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the
confidence tossing
then use a spatula and turn it over now
that's exactly what i want that nice
sort of crisp edge
around the side the color on the pancake
is so important
now roll it around and just let it slide
out beautifully
now for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully roll that
nice and tightly tuck it underneath
there
pull it back and roll
useful the delicious pancakes are ready
to eat
but with a simple dipping sauce there'll
be a real treat just mix
chopped coriander with natural yogurt
that's really nice cooling agent sit
there on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious
spicy pancakes amazing